today marks the 40th anniversary of the
deadliest aviation accident in history
it happened on the small Spanish island
of Tenerife off the coast of West Africa
two jumbo jets one American collided on
March 27 1977 Jeff Glor spoke with a
survivor of the deadly crash and looks
at how the factors that caused it are
still relevant today
Jeff good morning Charlie good morning
to you the unusual events and errors
that led to this disaster almost too
hard to believe even 40 years later an
act of terror at a different Airport
miscommunication weather and a pilots
mistake 583 people died but 61 survived
some are still with us today
they are typically very reluctant to
speak unless they believe it can help
for decades ago Tenerife the picturesque
quiet Spanish Canary Islands suddenly
home to the worst airline accident the
world had ever seen both then and now
historically it's an accident with an
almost mythical kind of aura around it
Patrick Smith is a commercial airline
pilot and author who was studied
Tenerife extensively where that comes
from I think is partly the bizarre
cascading series of ironies and
coincidences that led to it happening
beginning with the fact that neither of
these two planes was supposed to be at
Tenerife in the first place shifted to
Tenerife by a global threat that still
haunts the industry the Pan Am and KLM
jumbo jets were diverted to Tenerife
yesterday after a terrorist bomb
explosion at the Canary Islands main
airport in Las Palmas two 747s ended up
on an infrequently used runway as both
planes waited for several hours an
unusually dense fog descended eventually
the tower sent a message to a KLM flight
to taxi to the end of the runway and
turn around then instructed a Pan Am
flight to follow the KLM jet got into
position and announced they were ready
to go Pan Am Pilots heard this became
startled click their mic to say hey
we're still on the runway because of
radio interference the KLM plane didn't
get that message
the pilot thinking he was cleared for
takeoff sent his plane rock
on the runway with a Pan Am plane was
still taxiing Bob Bragg the first
officer of the Pan Am flight spoke to
CBS News in 2000 as soon as I saw the
man moving and coming at us I started
saying get off as we were turning to the
left I looked back out of my side window
and that's when he had lifted off the
ground and become airborne right as
close to us as I could seem the KLM
plane wasn't high enough on contact it
burst into flames and tore the top of
the Pan Am jet clear off everyone aboard
the KLM flight was killed but inside the
Pan Am flight some remained alive you
haven't talked about this publicly in in
almost 40 years right I wonder what
you're thinking here as the anniversary
arrives how fortunate I am including
Joan feathers we found outside Phoenix
just last week sat there thinking this
is the end
so as we made our way to the side of the
plane all these little implosions of
fire I just felt that it was imminent I
did not want to burn up so there was a
doctor from Chicago that had been in the
plane and he was down below and he said
jump I'll catch you what did you see
when you looked around I could tell that
there was a lot of these little fires
that were getting bigger so I kept
running and it wasn't maybe 15 seconds
and the plane went up like an atom bomb
it just and then huge fire investigators
pinned most of the blame on the KLM
pilot Jacob Venzon who was considered
such an exceptional flier he was the
face of the company he was on KLM
billboards in KLM advertisements one of
the the famous little nuggets of the
story is that when word got back to KLM
that one of their planes had crashed
they went looking for captain Van Zandt
and to go to the scene to figure out
what happened unaware that he was
actually the captain the Tenerife
disaster the worst in aviation history
remains relevant today we've engineered
away what used to be the causes of some
of the worst crashes ever but this one I
think
the fundamental cause or causes are
really still there that means crowded
runways it means potential pilot error
what else
runway congestion air traffic control
communications issues things like that
those problems are still out there
there's not a crisis but we shouldn't be
complacent about that as for Joan
feathers she's never stopped thinking
about Tenerife every year on March 27th
I remember and it's as if it happened
not long ago do you think about it on
when you every time every time you flush
every time you fly as Patrick Smith
rightly points out flying today has
never been safer the improvements made
since the 70s and 80s have been vast and
measurable
that's a communication and congestion
issues still come up and she still gets
on a plane and flies she still gets on a
plane yeah she says sometimes she sits
next to what she calls a white knuckled
fly or somebody who's very nervous yeah
and she usually she doesn't tell them
the story typically but she says that if
you only knew
that's so heartbreaking though Jeff a
series of things could have prevented
that and yet that it happened on the
ground - is also very frightening what's
the most alarming thing that they have
not fixed well the the radio frequencies
I mean the communication issues that
come up when when they send messages
between tower and and pilots sometimes
if they happen at the same time they
don't hear that's one of the many issues
that happened back then 40 years ago
Jeff thank you sure